prime minister Justin Trudeau was
invited as a special guest of the Nordic
Summit being held here in Iceland's
Westman Islands the recent turmoil in
Moscow is adding urgency to the meeting
of Nordic Nations that neighbor Russia
Trudeau held bilateral meetings with the
leaders of host country Iceland as well
as Denmark and Finland he congratulated
The Finnish leader on joining NATO we'll
talk about our strength on Ukraine we'll
talk about how we're watching carefully
the situation in in Russia right now as
as it's been
complex over the past couple of days I
just over the past hour have spoken with
president zielinski and President Biden
Sweden is also pushing to become a
member the Nordic Summit is largely seen
as a preview to next month's NATO Summit
in Lithuania
protecting Arctic sovereignty and
reducing energy dependence on Russia are
expected to dominate discussions as
Nordic Nations try to distance
themselves with Russia Iceland announced
it's closing its Embassy in Moscow later
this summer
Toria is read Global News Westman
Islands Iceland